et avec moi à l'irabet bonjour bonjour
mère de la commune de Trappes également
vice-président de l'agglomération de 50
ans en Yvelines on va faire un point
avec vous sur les grands projets de
Trappes en 2023 peut-être déjà un mot
pour revenir sur l'année 2022 on sait
que les derniers mois à Trappes avec une
réélection en 2021 on rappelle que vous
avez été lu pour la première fois en
2020 l'élection a été annulée vous êtes
réélu en 2021 il y a eu quelques
tensions on peut dire au sein du conseil
municipal avec l'opposition est-ce que
le climat est apaisé aujourd'hui à
trappe est-ce que on vous abordait
l'année 203 de la meilleure des manières
oui déjà 2022 a été une année sereine de
travail de remobilisation aussi des
équipes des élus et des équipes
municipales la rédélection dès le
premier tour contre le 4 listes aux
municipales après 60% à clarifier le jeu
les Trappistes ont confiance dans
l'équipe municipale et nous donne les
moyens politiques de mettre en oeuvre
notre programme dorénavant nous sommes
apaisés tranquille et nous mettons en
œuvre alors les grands projets en 2023
déjà forcément quand on passe aux
alentours de Trappes on voit qu'il y a
le petit travaux des gros travaux même
au niveau de la nationale 10 puisqu'on
rappelle que cette nationaliste va être
enfouie pour permettre aux deux parties
de Trappes entre guillemets d'être
d'être rassemblé le chantier à débutants
2021 on se souvient de la destruction du
pont à proximité de la mairie est-ce que
il y a de grandes étapes de ce projet
d'envergure en 2023 absolument notamment
la livraison du premier rond-point
d'entrée de ville qui va être vraiment
un élément de fluidification du trafic
puisque il permettra de plus facilement
accéder de la rd912 la départementale
qui arrive de Dreux pour aller vers
Paris et elle permettra également
ensuite d'engager la seconde phase de
travaux en fin d'année qui consistera à
creuser les fameuses tranchées centrales
d'enfouissement de la route nationale 10
donc la le contexte n'est pas simple
parce que tous ces travaux ça génère
évidemment des difficultés de
circulation en ville c'est aussi pour
nous une façon d'encourager les
habitants pour faciliter leur mobilité à
abandonner le véhicule individuel de
privilégier les mobilités douces la
marche à pied le vélo le bus on a des
transports en commun qui fonctionnent
pour l'instant pas trop mal sur sur trap
donc voilà il y aura
ce sera pas simple les Trappistes en ont
conscience on va serrer les dents
pendant quelques années mais on va
pouvoir recoudre cette ville qui a été
déchirée effectivement pendant très
longtemps par la route nationale 10 mais
il faut garder en tête que c'est une
enfouissement partielle malheureusement
c'est pas l'enfouissement total comme à
Neuilly par exemple ça reste un projet
ambitieux mais partiel 130 millions
d'euros d'investissement tout de même
c'est un projet dont on parlait de
depuis nombreuses années à Trappes et
qui voit en fin de jour et fin des
travaux prévus un petit peu avant 2030
2028 plutôt on espère normalement les
travaux de RN 10 pure avec la fourniture
des trois plateaux qui vont permettre de
recoudre la ville en deux sont prévus en
2027 au plus tard ensuite il y aura des
travaux d'aménagement du plateau qui
nous emmèneront en effet jusqu'à 2030
alors la ville de Trappes aussi va
connaître de grands projets en 2023
notamment le stade Gravot alors
qu'est-ce qui va se passer autour de ce
stade graveau alors c'est un très grand
équipement sportif qui était vétuste qui
est le long de la nationaliste justement
et qui va qui est un peu l'écrin du fou
qui sera l'écrin du football à trappe on
a un club de foot qui est le plus grand
des Yvelines 1200 licenciés pas
négligeable euh et l'idée c'est de leur
donner c'est aussi le maire actuel et
l'ancien adjoint sport vous voyez donc
c'est de mobiliser des moyens pour
pouvoir faire une un équipement sportif
neuf avec deux terrains synthétiques une
tribune de 500 places digne d'un club
qui pourrait se visser demain
au niveau national par exemple les
ambitions de monter encore plus haut en
tout cas je pense que le but des élus
c'est d'avoir des politiques en général
c'est de prévoir l'avenir et c'est de
donner les moyens de mettre en œuvre des
projets ambitieux c'est pas moi qui
dirige le club de football je pense que
je l'ai déjà dit à mes collègues maires
les ambitions sportives sur ce
territoire il faut les penser à
l'échelle de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin que demain un club
intercommunal de football pour l'équipe
une qui viendrait mêler les talents de
chaque ville et les moyens de chaque
ville les entreprises locales les
sponsors etc permettrait pourquoi pas de
viser le niveau national moi j'en rêve
que Saint-Quentin joue au niveau
national mais pour cela il faut un écrin
il faut un stade et Gravaud le sera on
va labelliser le foot le terrain de foot
qui sera probablement le seul de 50 ans
en Yvelines labellisé au niveau national
et ensuite on va en profiter aussi pour
apporter à cette à ce grand site des
fonctionnalités supplémentaires
confortable un club house pour le club
de foot une salle de musculation
également pour la préparation physique
des joueurs et des autres clubs une
salle de boxe voilà on va essayer de
répondre à des terrains de pétanque un
certain nombre de besoins qui sont
anciens sur la ville de trappes et on
fait un investissement majeur de près de
8 millions d'euros pour faire de gravots
à l'écrin du sport à trappe en matière
d'équipement il y a aussi le ramène le
réaménagement du square Pergaud qui est
prévu avec aussi la population qui sera
associée à ce projet qu'il a été depuis
le début alors j'en suis
particulièrement fier parce que ça
incarne la méthode de mon équipe
municipale l'idée c'est de verdir un
quartier qui aujourd'hui laissez un peu
à l'abandon en friche et où les familles
les enfants Les grands-parents les
jeunes ne trouvent pas à s'épanouir avec
des aires de jeux vieillissantes on est
à cheval entre des parcelles de 50 ans
Yvelines de trappes et d'autres
opérateurs donc on va vraiment sur un
mail qui permet de relier la ville de
trappes à l'île de loisirs avec une
passerelle qui donne accès à l'île de
loisirs on va totalement le rénover et
on a décidé que ce n'était pas au maire
de trappes de définir ce qui est bon
trop mauvais c'est aux habitants de le
faire donc on a travaillé avec les
enfants avec les mamans les papas les
grands-parents avec les jeunes chacun a
eu le droit à un espace de travail avec
les services municipaux pour imaginer le
devenir de ce grand site et ça a donné
lieu à un schéma qui maintenant en cours
de mise en œuvre plus d'un million de
travaux un million 300000 € de travaux
mais un site qui sera remarquable et qui
va inspirer nos autres projets pendant
le mandat si vous parlez de
participation des trappistes des
citoyens prévoyaient aussi une enveloppe
de 300.000 euros de budget participatif
pour les assemblées citoyennes tout à
fait l'idée pour nous c'est vraiment de
s'appuyer sur l'expertise des habitants
les gens sont il n'y a pas que les élus
qui peuvent décider il faut partager le
pouvoir la démocratie ce n'est pas que
l'exercice par une trentaine des du
majoritaires de leur prérogatives c'est
aussi des allers-retours permanents moi
j'attends pas les élections pour aller
en direction des habitants j'aime
travailler avec eux au quotidien et bien
les assemblées citoyennes c'est une
dynamique nouvelle où on dit aux
habitants organisez-vous un assemblée
c'est pas besoin des élus on vous fait
confiance travailler entre vous fixez
vos priorités débattez responsabiliser
vous aussi on vous contient un vrai
budget vous pouvez investir décider de
d'aménager un square de refaire une
portion de voirie de réaménager la
sécurité dans un carrefour vous pouvez
dire que la priorité dans votre quartier
c'est tel élément et vous pouvez décider
entre vous sans qu'on ait à trancher
sans que le maire n'a donné son avis dès
lors que c'est dans les clous juridiques
financiers etc vous pouvez mettre en
œuvre des projets d'investissement sur
votre quartier on continue ce tour
d'horizon avec trappe plage et la
création de jeux d'eau plus que de jeux
d'eau trap plage c'est pareil vous savez
on avait une ville assez bien équipée
trap a été vraiment pendant des
décennies assez bien équipés mais on
avait des équipements vieillissants trap
plage s'en était un peu la caricature un
sable qui avait une vingtaine d'années
quasiment qui était devenu compliqué à
nettoyer des équipements pas très
ludiques et moi je pense qu'il faut le
meilleur pour trap et pour les
Trappistes parce que vraiment j'aime
profondément cette population et je
pense qu'elle mérite le meilleur de ce
que nous pouvons offrir nous la
République les institutions etc et quand
on va dans des aires de jeu dans des
parcs ludiques aqualudiques etc bah on
voit des choses formidables on pourquoi
pas chez nous on attrape donc j'ai
décidé que sur trap plage c'était déjà
le travail de l'ancien mandat de l'adjou
en sport que j'étais mais en prolongeant
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'un travail
participatif là encore avec les usagers
on allait faire de trap plage un site
remarquable extraordinaire c'est un beau
cadeau qu'on prépare pour cet été au
trappistes il y a un bâtiment qui a une
grande histoire derrière lui c'est le
grenier à sel cette salle de cinéma bien
connue à Trappes aussi gros effort
d'aménagement puisque le budget de 1,3
millions d'euros absolument on a une
vous savez ce cinéma il est cinéma
depuis un siècle et c'est un vieux
bâtiment qui date pour les premières
traces de du 16e siècle donc on le but
le but c'est vraiment d'en garder la
coquille et l'aspect charmant vous savez
c'est un bâtiment en pierre de meulière
c'est un vrai voilà c'est un vrai site
culturel de trappe et on va le
moderniser puisque aujourd'hui il est un
peu obsolète dans son fonctionnement ces
sièges son inclinaison la visibilité de
l'écran donc on va vraiment en faire un
cinéma moderne confortable aussi c'est
important quand on va au cinéma c'est
pour être bien installé avec un accueil
une borne d'accueil un espace d'accueil
beaucoup plus convivial qui permettent
d'accueillir comme dans n'importe quel
sémile cinéma du 21e siècle donc on est
assez fier de cette équipe et je vous le
glisse là parce que c'est une idée que
je creuse pourquoi pas le renommer et
lui donner le nom d'Omar Sy un grand
buteurs
de trappes et lui bien sûr du monde du
cinéma à moi aussi peut-être sur un mot
sur les travaux le démarrage les
démarrages de travaux d'une épicerie
sociale à Trappes c'est bien ça ouais
c'est pareil l'idée c'est aussi de
redonner de la dignité à ceux qui en
sont privés c'est aussi ça la fonction
de la République nous avons attrape
comme dans tout notre commune des
personnes sans domicile fixe des
personnes qui n'ont pas lieu pour se
doucher pour laver leur linge pour
trouver une oreille compatissante pour
pouvoir boire un café au chaud notamment
maintenant en hiver ou c'est
particulièrement douloureux mais on
oublie pas également les personnes SDF
l'été aujourd'hui ils sont accueillis
dans des conditions que je n'estime pas
être à la hauteur j'en ai honte voilà
c'est comme ça depuis très longtemps
malheureusement mais moi je suis pas à
l'aise les agents travaillent dans des
conditions dégradées et les personnes
sans domicile fixe sont accueillies
vraiment son respect pour leur dignité
donc on va investir dans un bâtiment qui
est tout près de la ville et on a une
idée innovante dans ce bâtiment il y
avait une épicerie qui était un bâtiment
municipal l'épicerie était géré par un
commerçant ce commerçant a décidé de
partir à la retraite on a repris le
commerce et on a décidé qu'on ferait une
épicerie sociale et un espace solidarité
donc vous et moi on pourra les faire nos
courses dans cet épicerie en payant nos
courses habituellement mais une personne
dans la difficulté sociale orientée par
les services sociaux viendra comme tous
les autres comme vous et moi acheter ces
produits mais elle paiera beaucoup moins
cher voire à leur accès à la gratuité
sur certains produits mais elle sera
respectée parce qu'on ne saura pas si
elle est en difficulté ou pas ce sera un
client comme les autres qui se
présentera dans cet épicerie et puis on
aura évidemment des douches toutes
neuves de à qui respecte la
confidentialité également et simplement
la dignité des personnes il y a une
question aussi qui revient dans les
préoccupations essentielles pour tous
les maires que nous recevons c'est la
hausse de des factures énergétiques
quels sont les mesures que que vous
prenez pour réduire justement cette
facture pour vous donner un peu
mais on a cherché à réduire notamment
dans les bâtiments administratifs on a
décidé également de faire des économies
d'énergie j'avais commencé en tant
qu'adjoint sport dans les gymnases j'ai
déployé depuis que je suis maire la même
stratégie dans les écoles on remplace
les nos éclairages dans les écoles par
du LED c'est beaucoup plus évidemment
vertueux sur le plan environnemental
c'est plus économique le retour sur
investissement est dans 4 à 5 ans vous
voyez donc c'est extrêmement important
de le faire vite et bien donc on l'a
fait on investissant plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros et puis on a on
s'est engagé on va en parler tout à
l'heure peut-être sur un grand projet de
réseau de chaleur urbain pour exploiter
la géothermie la chaleur qui est sous
nos pieds pour chauffer les logements
dans quelques années plutôt que de
consommer du gaz qui émet beaucoup de
CO2 et qui nous coûte une fortune deux
sujets également que je voulais aborder
avec vous avant qu'on passe à
l'interview Express c'est l'exercice de
tous les mers auquel se prête tous les
mers sur le réseau de chaleur urbain
puisqu'on parle d'énergie il y a aussi
des nouveautés en 2023 absolument vous
savez on a attrape 7000 logements
sociaux on a une centaine de bâtiments
municipaux on a un hôpital privé qui
consomme énormément d'énergie on a une
cinquantaine de copropriétés
donc c'est énormément d'équipements
collectif de bâtiments collectifs
également d'habitation dans un périmètre
assez restreint trap et une ville assez
dense très étendue c'est pas manileamo
ou voisin de Bretonneux etc donc on est
une ville où l'idée de créer un réseau
de chaleur quel que soit la source
d'énergie d'aller brancher les
équipements actuels pour leur fournir
une énergie pas cher et une énergie
propre c'est relativement simple à faire
donc on a commencé par une rapides de
faisabilité qui a confirmé avec trois
opérateurs différents que trap était une
ville intéressante pour mettre en place
un réseau de chaleur et moi j'ai tenu à
ce que l'on exploite une énergie très
décarbonée donc on va faire un forage de
test pour vérifier si nous pouvons
exploiter l'énergie géothermique
c'est-à-dire l'eau très chaude qui a
2000 mètres sous nos pieds voilà parce
qu'on a une nappe d'eau chaude qui
traverse la région Île-de-France donc
c'est un test de forage si ce test est
concluant on pourra déclencher
l'exploitation de la géothermie si ce
test n'est pas concluant on pourrait
exploiter la buse qu'on appelle la
biomasse c'est-à-dire le les bois les
restes de gestion de des forêts
françaises notamment pour pouvoir
produire de la chaleur et la cheminée
chez habitants pour les chauffer avec
une économie avec une énergie propre
verte renouvelable mais surtout avec des
prix stables vous voyez le gaz monte
l'énergie géothermique ça montre très
peu ou quasiment pas donc ça permet de
concilier écologique et solidarité
écologie et pouvoir d'achat des ménages
dernier mot sur la sécurité avec
l'ambition aussi de renforcer la police
municipale c'est ce que nous ont depuis
le début du mandat nous avions des
effectifs très faibles et très peu
présents en ville vous rendez compte une
police municipale qui ferme ses portes à
17h c'est à dire au moment où on a le
plus besoin d'elle donc aujourd'hui on a
déjà des équipages de police municipale
qui circulent la nuit notamment
plusieurs fois par semaine et nous avons
l'ambition de continuer à monter en
puissance pour systématiser cette
présence et nous sommes aujourd'hui à
une douzaine d'agents municipaux en
comptant les ASVP les gardiens de police
municipales l'ambition à la fin du
mandat c'est de monter à vin donc nous
recrutons je profite pour passer un
message si des agents municipaux des
policiers municipaux des gendarmes des
policiers nationaux parce que nous
allons voir recruter beaucoup qui
viennent de la gendarmerie ou de la
police nationale veulent nous rejoindre
nous sommes nous aurons les bras et nous
avons une grande ambition en matière de
sécurité publique à Trappes et pour
terminer cette interview on passe à
l'interview express
[Musique]
le principe Ali rabais cinq questions
des réponses courtes un oui un nom un
pour ou contre une petite explication si
il y en a besoin alors est-ce qu'en 2023
première question vous augmenterez les
impôts locaux à Trappes alors non et on
les a même baissé en 2021 on est la
seule ville probablement de France à
l'avoir fait côté circulation des
communes ont opté pour la limitation à
30 km/h sur sur leur voie est-ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre une telle idée
j'y réfléchi je pense que c'est une
bonne idée dans certains secteurs Trap
est pleine de route départementale donc
c'est plus compliqué pour nous certaines
communes ont fait aussi le choix de
mettre du bio dans les cantines c'est le
cas de votre commune est-ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre l'obligation du bio
dans les cantines françaises évidemment
il faut faire attention à ce qu'on donne
à manger dans les assiettes de nos
enfants on est déjà au double de ce que
la loi nous impose on est à 40% à
Trappes il y a malheureusement eu aussi
dans l'actualité des mers des élus
victimes d'agression ou de menaces
est-ce que dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions vous êtes senti déjà menacé
bien sûr ça m'est arrivé bon c'est peut
vous dire j'ai été protégé par des
policiers du ministère de l'intérieur
pendant un mois parce que j'étais
directement victime de menaces à
l'époque où il y a eu une polémique
attrape sur un prof de philosophie qui a
stigmatisé la ville ça m'arrive je suis
assez à l'aise assez confortable avec la
population franchement je me sens
protégé par ma population en réalité
parce que malgré tout vous êtes un maire
heureux jamais aussi épuisé que eux
merci Ali rabais et très bonne année
2023 dans la commune de Trappes je le
rappelle le maire de la commune de
Trappes